今日はあずみ社長です haribo の新作の組で参加ね
普通動画紹介するのもあまりしたくないんだというちょっと飽きてきちゃったんでこう
言うなんか明らかにえーっ
かそう言うにょ村ヌー動かすとか
ねちょっと食べていこうと思います大冒険はちょっと最近
いや入っちゃってるわけじゃないと思うんですけど
ふーん
haribo たんだ
味です
ヴィレッジヴァンだったので所々ちょっと感じというか中国語ですね
中国語で書いてありますな津波にちょっと戦術ひたぎさんとお会いして外れちゃったん
ですけどすごいこうなんか
いいとそうな感じでしたちょっとこうインスパイアされたので
ちょっとね今日ははじめずポイントをつけると思います
やっていいのかたこんな
いいでしょ
レンズもダメなんか行うそうだ次いでまた配合ですよ
今度はパンダーズです道路観前街してほしくないんですけど haribo とか
美味しいです
ヴィレッジヴァンガードにおいてやるかで5月と変なのが多くて
パンッパンだったり監督
たんだ何だろう
う思う
なんか黒い何か黒いまあまあパンダってるジャパン取っていくんです
すごいですね何から店員さんから聞いたんですけどこういうなんかを
ちょっと入っちゃってる系のハリボーわーヴィレッジヴァンガード限定だシーンで2に
お店に行っても売ってないと思ってぜひ
ヴィレッジヴァンガードに入ってください
なら宣伝みたいになっちゃったねー
じゃあさっそく食べます
難関
やっぱり赤そうなきゃいいじゃないです
アレキ
ブルーベリーの味がしますたんだなじゃないんだこれ
なんか
安心した自分とこうちょっとがっかりするジャパンがこーいます何もて硬い組なんです
けど結構なふわふわしててヤジもちゃんとブルーベリーの味がします
普通に何か美味しいですねもっとこうなんか
すごい味カトパンとなんだっていうぐらいのがさーん言葉なんか
通過料理の香辛料全種類作って味付けしましたんだよもういたよしれない
アジトがだと思ったんですけど思って美味しかった
あるいはさん次はねまだちょっと奇抜なもう
もう云々ってなるじゃないのちょっと過ぎ夏の張りも期待しております
ジャガー
dea